The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we had a
big lecture last time
on perfect insurance and
implications for targeting,
and policy, and evaluations.
There is a series
of lectures now
that have to do with working
off of that basic risk sharing
framework.
Today we're going to talk about
the implications for what we
should see in rates of return.
And then next class,
we're going to talk
about alternative models of what
we might see in the consumption
data.
And then the lecture
after that we're
going to return to the
perfect market model
and think about labor supply.
And then finally, we're going
to get to explicit obstacles
to trade.
I must say that rather
than put off the obstacles,
we've been noting
and even talking
about alternative
models along the way.
Because these
benchmarks are sometimes
rejected and you're going to
see that a bit today as well.
So this perfect market
standard within villages
that has to do with
relatives and friends
interacting with each
other has implications
for how you adjust for risk.
And we're going to do
that with a vengeance.
But it will turn
out that it does--
that framework allows us
to distinguish aggregate
from idiosyncratic risk.
And the idiosyncratic
risk should not
be showing up in rates of
return, but it does at the end.
And then I'll say a few
words about what else
we know about the
tie data in terms
of the decomposition
of volatility
linking back to a
paper we saw the very
first lecture on quantifying
the growth rates by sector.
But we're going to
do it by wealth.
At least I'll say a
few words about it.
And then I'm going to toward the
end of the class sort of return
to this idea that
either things aren't
perfect and/or people
are making mistakes.
And we'll do that in
some unusual contexts,
one that has to do
with data from Sweden,
an unusually rich
database from Sweden,
and another that has to
do with the US airlines.
But the basic frameworks
that are getting
used, whether in the
developing context, or Sweden,
or US airlines, are
basically all the same.
So there is a strong
complementarity
across these papers.
This paper with Chris has
been in the works for a while.
But we are now able to use you
know 13 years of monthly data.
So we are doing
better than before.
So we want to talk about risk
and return of productive assets
in developing countries.
We already looked at some
of the slides showing
how rates of return differ a
lot across different households,
differ in large part
by wealth and how
poor people have relatively
high rates of return.
And they're saving.
And they're accumulating
assets and so on.
Another way people look at
rates of return is to say,
you know, well, some people
are more talented than others.
So if we look at
rates of return,
we get some notion of
underlying productivity
as in TFP and so on.
We've had many
lectures about TFP
and coefficients in
front multiplying
in front of production
functions and so on.
But correct me if I'm wrong.
Nowhere in any of that stuff
did we ever adjust for risk.
So what's the intuition
for adjusting for risk?
Well, if you want to look at
compensating differentials,
the higher the risk of a
project, the higher the rate
of return ought to be.
Other things equal to
compensate for that risk.
You know, like junk
bonds have higher yields
and so on and so forth.
So maybe these guys with
seemingly very high rates
of return actually are
just doing risky things.
And indeed, if enough of them
do risky things and on average
some of them succeed
and maybe that
would generate the
high rate of return.
So we really need to think
about how to measure the risk.
And we're going to
rely on finance theory.
But I'll be very
careful to sort of build
into it the economic models.
You may learn a little bit of
finance jargon along the way.
But I'm not going
to start with that.
I'll get you up to speed.
It's really not that hard when
you look at the equations.
OK, so what do we find?
We do find that higher
risk is associated
with higher rate of return.
But the risk that we're
going to be concentrating on
in the model is not
idiosyncratic risk.
It's village level risk.
So when you think about
households together pooling
resources, as in a
risk sharing syndicate,
they would care about say
aggregate consumption should
move individual consumption.
And idiosyncratic
income shock should not
have an influence
on consumption.
So when is something
really valuable?
A project is
valuable when it has
a return, which is negatively
correlated with the village
average return.
So that the resources
come in when you need it.
So the quote market,
the way the finance guys
would use it, for
us is the village.
And indeed, the more a household
has a return on its projects
that are correlated with
the village average return,
the higher is going to be the
measured expected or average
return on that
household's assets.
And we have all kinds of ways
of adjusting for human capital
and so on, which I'll get into.
As I said though,
it does in the end
leave some idiosyncratic risk.
And that's also generating
higher expected returns.
Aggregate and idiosyncratic
risk is negatively
correlated with age.
So the older a household
head basically,
the quote, less risky
things that they're doing.
But both in the idiosyncratic
and aggregate sense
they tend to do things which are
less correlated with a village
average.
It's negative with wealth.
Meaning the lower is wealth, the
higher both the idiosyncratic
and aggregate.
So this gets us into
poor people and how
exposed are they to risk?
We've seen a bit of that
already in risk and return
in village India that there
are some landless laborers
and labor income that tends to
move consumption around more.
This is a bit different way
of measuring it in the sense
that we're not going to look so
much at the consumption data.
We're going to assume everyone
is in this risk sharing
syndicate.
But we turn around
and see what is
reflected in rates of return.
And in particular,
relatively poor people
are more exposed to risk.
But it's not just their
own idiosyncratic risk.
It's the aggregate risk.
And there is a little bit
of role for education.
But it's kind of problematic.
And there's some selection
bias that I might
talk about when we get there.
And then this is
maybe the punch line.
If you want to
think about talent,
then you want to adjust
for all sources of risk.
And when we do that, we
find who are seemingly
the really productive
people in the village.
And all of a sudden, it's
the higher wealth people
who have the higher risk
adjusted rate of return
and female headed households.
So relatively wealthy
females actually
dominate in terms of getting
a higher rate of return.
So we have a basic model.
They're going to be j households
and l production activities.
Each activity utilizes
capital as an input.
And let's simplify and
say all these technologies
produce the same thing,
consumption goods.
And we'll simplify further and
assume all the technologies are
linear.
Yeah, Matt.
AUDIENCE: Can I
just actually ask
a couple of things
about previous slides?
So are we assuming there's
no sharing between them?
PROFESSOR: So we
are again, going
to take a stand on our baseline.
And it's actually
going to be all four
villages in a province,
not just a single village.
But then we go back and check
for villages individually.
And we actually go back further
and look one network at a time.
The basic results don't change.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Another thing which I
don't really understand
is when we have this
result that returns
risk adjusted returns
are lower for those
with lower [INAUDIBLE].
How do we think about
in terms of one story's
that the people with
low initial wealth,
they're very productive
people amongst them.
But [INAUDIBLE] get sufficient
size of their business.
So their marginal returns
might be really high.
And the average returns
as well, depending on--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so this paper isn't
going to help much with that.
Because we're going to
assume linear technologies.
And margins are going
to be equal to averages.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: And more
generally, you know,
wealth is clearly an
endogenous variable.
So we're not saying high wealth
is causing people to have--
I mean, it's more likely
the other way around.
But yeah, we've gone
through a series of models
where wealth helps
overcome constraints.
The first four lectures
were like that.
So in a way, this is another
fact finding mission.
But it's not just
data summaries.
It's looking at the data
through the lens of the model.
And you have to make some
assumptions to do that.
OK, so we have j
production activities.
We're going to start
the economy off
with some aggregate wealth, w.
And those are basically
the projects, the assets,
or the trees if you like.
And those projects
are going to have
rates of return, the fruit.
So at the beginning
of the period,
the total sort of
wealth available
is the sum of the
trees and the fruit.
So this is a standard kind
of solo reversible capital
assumption that the assets
can basically be sold.
There's no irreversibility.
You can convert them into
consumption if you choose to.
So we're going to
have a social planner
sort of directing
the show, which
is not to say this might not
decentralize in some way.
That said, I want to
emphasize it's not
like finance in the sense that
people participate on the New
York Stock Exchange or
the financial markets,
and they're buying
and selling stocks.
We don't even have the data
of all these capital goods.
That's not the mechanism.
This planner's problem may
be decentralized in some way.
But it's just much
more straightforward,
just like when we
did the risk sharing
stuff not to
necessarily be forced
into some interpretation.
We're just going to solve the
planning problem directly.
So somehow or other, a
household is assigned.
Household j is assigned capital
and is operating project type
i.
And this is the
net rate of return.
Notice that we allow
individuals to vary
in their rates of return.
The planner could
take advantage if it
knows that some people are
better than other people
at doing things.
So we're not just
getting rid of talent.
We're embedding it at some
level in these rates of return.
And then they have basically
the tree and the fruit.
That's their starting point.
And then they get taxes
and transfers, these Taus.
I mean, here it's written
positive as if it's incoming
and adds to the resources
of the household.
But in fact, like a
risk sharing group
you can give and get and
contribute to the social fund.
So the planning problem
is to maximize discounted
weighted expected utility.
So these Lambda j weights
are the pareto weights
for households type j.
They're not necessarily the
same over all the households.
And this whole term here
is the utility function,
which as noted, is just
the return on the trees
plus these transfers.
And then discounted
expected return for tomorrow
I usually write as Beta.
But anyway, it's an
intertemporal discount rate.
And so you have the
value function today
given wealth today and expected
value of wealth tomorrow w
prime.
And wealth today
can be allocated
into basically consumption.
So this is just
summing over not only
over all projects for household
j, but all households j.
So this is again,
just consumption.
So consumption plus
capital allocated tomorrow
equals total wealth, pretty
standard kind of growth market
structure.
And what is total
wealth of the economy?
It's basically not only
the fruit of the trees,
but the trees themselves.
So you can take this expression
and put it on the right hand
side if you want.
Because they have
pre-existing capital.
They have the rate
of return on that.
You've got total
resources available.
You can allocate
it to consumption
or set some aside to continue
the capital stock for tomorrow.
And so we just substitute
in the expressions
for tomorrow's wealth and
today's wealth for that matter.
And then this odd
looking thing here
is just a substitution
from the previous equation.
But there's a common
term on both sides.
That's why it looks
kind of weird.
Because this is really 1
plus r times k over here.
But there's also a 1
plus r times k here.
And the rk things
are canceling out.
So this is just
straightforward algebra.
So we're going to
maximize this thing
by choosing the transfer as
Tau j and the assignments
of tomorrow's capital stock.
AUDIENCE: Was there
supposed to be uncertainty?
It's just their
return on capital?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, there's no
preference shocks here.
AUDIENCE: What's the
process [INAUDIBLE]??
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Don't
have to specify yet.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: That's
probably a good thing.
OK, so if you looked, we've
actually seen this before.
But it's explicit here again.
Consumption and capital
are interrelated through
this resource constraint.
So when you take a derivative
to maximize with respect
to the transfers, you'll
pick up a derivative
in the utility function.
And the sum of total
transfers is down here
in the resource constraint.
And there's a Lagrange
multiplier in front of it,
right?
So you're going to
get margin weighted,
margin utility of
consumption today
equal to a Lagrange multiplier.
And when you
differentiate with respect
to the choice of tomorrow's
capital stock k prime,
well, that's going to
enter in tomorrow's value.
So you'll have a derivative
of the value function
and then internally this
sort of rate of return.
And this prime thing is also
entering into the same resource
constraint.
So you're going to
get the same Lagrange
multiplier as on consumption.
So here is a summary
of those words.
Weighted margin
utilities are equated
across all the households to a
common contemporaneous Lagrange
multiplier.
And then this is kind of a--
it's an exactly Euler equation
for capital accumulation.
This is the price
of capital today.
It's how much consumption
you're giving up.
And this is expected
discounted value
of having capital tomorrow.
It's the derivative
of the value function
times the rate of
return, depending
on which project i
and J is being chosen.
Note that this is for every
project, every capital stock
of type i for household j.
Now, so far I've talked
about real assets.
But it's not too hard.
And we do actually allow
external borrowing.
You could imagine a village
is able to borrow in land.
Or the whole set
of four villages
have some relationship with the
rest of the external economy.
That still leaves
this sub problem.
I mean, throwing
these things in might
deliver some extra conditions
that we're ignoring.
But what we're doing is not
inconsistent with having
this equation.
All right, so if you
just take this one
and divide both sides
through by Mu, you get this.
And then you take the
expectation operator
in front of everything,
including Mu,
even though it's not random
from the point of day t.
And then you can
rewrite this guy here
as something called m or m
prime, since in effect it's
for tomorrow.
And this r prime ij is
basically capital R is little r.
One plus r is sort of
the gross rate of return.
So this is hopefully
not mysterious.
It's just basically a
relabeling of variables.
And it's like the
Euler equation.
But if you want to
impress your friends
and bewilder your enemies,
you call this thing
the stochastic discount factor.
But all it is is the
way society as a whole
is discounting the future.
It's tomorrow's sort of shadow
price of resources relative
to today's.
So you're discounting tomorrow.
And it's random.
Because these rates
of return are random.
And so the amount of resources
available in the economy
is likely random.
So it's stochastic.
There's a danger in
talking to someone
about stochastic
discount factors.
Because the conversation
will keep going.
And you may learn more
or get bewildered.
But anyway, as promised,
we'll keep track of this.
So it's true for all
households, all sectors.
And the finance
jargon is we just
looked at something
called the pricing
equation in the consumption
based asset pricing world.
But for us it's just an
Euler equation holding
at say the village or let's
call it township level.
Another thing you may or may not
know or remember from finance
is you can take assets
and bundle them.
So you can have a
particular asset
held by a particular
household, a project.
Or you could take a
collection of assets.
That Euler equation has to
hold for any asset individually
and all assets collectively.
You can bundle, package,
rebundle anyway you want.
And anything that's
actually held--
by the way, there's sort of
out of equilibrium projects
we're not seeing.
They wouldn't satisfy
the Euler equation.
They have a low rate of return
relative to the other ones.
So we're only seeing
these equilibrium ones
that the households
actually hold.
And of course, we're looking at
the data at what they actually
hold.
I'm mentioning this
bundling because--
and you'll see it again.
But we might as well get
our minds around it here.
We are going to look at a
household's rate of return.
And typical households, as you
know, you've already seen this,
are doing more than one thing.
Some of the incoming money
is from labor supply.
They have crops,
maybe multiple crops.
Some of them have both that
and a business and so on.
We try very hard to assign
these assets individually
to particular activities.
But it's kind of treacherous.
And we're likely
to make mistakes.
What do you do with a
pickup truck for example?
Is that just used in farming?
Or they're going to the bank.
They're taking the
kids to school.
And so rather than
face all of that
we just aggregate up
over all the activities
any particular household
is doing and call that
a collection of assets.
And the Euler
equation should apply.
Now, remember a little
bit of your sort
of econometrics with means
and variances or easy mistakes
to make.
The expectation of
two random variables
is not just the product
of the expectations.
You've got to adjust
for the covariance,
unless this happens to be zero.
But this covariance is
going to be crucial for us.
Because you can see already
it's the covariance between dare
I say it, the stochastic
discount factor,
which reflects the community's
relative valuation of resources
and the particular return on
project i held by household j.
So since we already had
this equal to 1 as the Euler
equation, right?
So now we just substitute
this stuff into here.
And we get this.
And you could basically divide
through by the expectation
of m prime.
You're going to get 1 over
that here, get rid of it here.
Get the covariance
divided by it here.
And then you divide
and multiply,
which doesn't do any
harm, by the variance
of m prime and rearrange terms.
So you get this thing.
So we're finally
arriving at something
close to what we want, which
is the expected rate of return,
which is going to
be in the data,
the average return for household
j over all the time periods.
Not quite.
It sort of looks like
a linear function,
something with an intercept,
and then Beta Lambda.
Beta, and finance guys talk
about betas all the time.
Beta for us just means sort
of the normalized covariance
between the returns on ij
and the stochastic discount
factor, which I already
pointed to above.
It's normalized by
the overall variance.
So that's kind of
the risk factor,
or the quantity of risk.
And this other thing could
be called the price of risk.
But it's nothing
other than this.
It's the variance
divided by the mean.
It almost looks like a
coefficient of variation,
like Sigma squared divided
by Mu or something.
And there's a name for it.
And I'll tell you what
it is in a second.
All right, so this is
what I said already.
Quantities, prices--
oh, and one more thing.
What was that intercept?
Well basically,
let's just define
this thing, this Gamma,
well, it was already
defined to be 1 over the
expectation of m prime.
But let's call it
the risk free return.
First of all, why
is there no risk?
Because all the
variability in the economy
is in m prime or the one that
we care about for that equation.
And we've already
taken the expectation.
So there's nothing random left.
So this is a number.
It's not something stochastic.
It should be obvious.
But I always do it myself, which
is take that to be an asset,
plug that back into the
asset Euler equation
that we already have and
thus convince yourself
that that equation applies
for the risk free return.
And you'll get this
right back again, OK?
So anyway, the point is risk
free because the covariance
of this risk free rate with
m prime is 0 by construction.
So let's just look
at this again.
This is the rate of return
of the mean, or average, rate
of return on project ij.
Subtract off the risk free rate.
This is the return differential.
This is how much the--
in finance, it would be
like the junk bond premium
over and above treasuries.
And so that difference
is sort of the premium
that you get for
holding a risky asset.
And it's linearly
related to the covariance
of that asset with the market.
So again, I'm going back
and forth a bit more
with this finance language.
But it's just all right
off the Euler equation.
This is just standard
sort of manipulation.
So we can even make
it more obvious
if you're wondering
what m prime really is.
Let's go with quadratic utility.
So this is the form of it.
The community's value function
as a function of wealth
is just basically the squared
of the difference between wealth
and some subsistence level with
a coefficient in front of it.
So of course, if you
take the derivative of it
with respect to w
the twos cancel out.
And you get eta times this
difference, which is linear,
by the way.
That's huge.
So marginal value of
wealth is linear in wealth.
That's what you
get at a quadratic.
And then you just substitute
our expression for w
prime tomorrow into
that expression
and do a little relabeling.
So all of a sudden, this
looks like the return
on the village average and the
village average capital stock.
OK, the village
average capital stock
is the sum of the
capital stocks allocated
over all the projects
and all the households,
as it should be to
be in total, right?
And then what is the
rate of return on it?
Well basically, it's like
a capital weighted return.
So the total return
is coming from a bunch
of individual projects.
So you just take the return
on all the individual projects
but weight them by the
capital being allocated
to those projects
and renormalize
by the total capital stock.
So it's a portfolio
weighted return.
That's just a definition.
But of course, then
it looks like this.
And you take this up
here and this here.
And you realize that
there's things canceling.
And that's why it's
really just equal to this.
But we'll use this now.
So m prime, which is
the derivative tomorrow,
is just this thing
divided by Mu.
Remember we have to take
the current shadow price
and divide through.
And then this is all
additive and linear.
So we get this.
And now, m prime here
looks like this plus this.
This looks like a
constant term that doesn't
depend on the rate of return.
And this is a coefficient
premultiplying
the rate of return.
So it's starting to look like
a pretty convenient equation
for the stochastic
discount factor.
It's linear, linear in the
village rate of return.
And again, we have this
thing we already derived,
which was a manipulation
of the Euler equation.
And everywhere you
see m prime, you
start substituting
a minus brm prime.
And then you got to
remember certain rules
about covariance operators
and variance operators.
Variance operators will square
coefficients in front of them.
Covariance operators will
bring the coefficient outside.
There's a lot of
substitutions here.
there's b's and b squares.
And they're going to
cancel with each other.
And you end up with this thing.
So this says the expected
return, or sample
average return, should
just be the covariance
of the return with the market
with the village average
aggregate.
By the way, we know
how to construct that.
Because we have it in the data.
And we have the
variance as well.
And then this is just
the sort of coefficient
that multiplies it.
But that's what I was saying
about that coefficient
of variation.
It's a variance
divided by a mean.
So where have we ended up?
Well, with that quadratic
we now have pretty much
an exact expression that
the expected rate of return
on project i run by
household j should just
be a linear function with
a common constant term that
has nothing do with
i and j and then
the covariance of
that household's
return with the village average
return, which is something
we can compute.
Because if you start thinking
about this like a regression,
we'll know this from the data.
We'll know this from the data.
I'll tell you how to
get it in a minute.
And we'll just estimate
Lambda and Gamma.
Well, not quite, Gamma we can
do something special with.
But that's the idea.
So I've said this already.
But it bears repeating.
Our stuff looks a
lot like this cap m.
But the mechanism
is very different.
We do not have
households trading assets
that are priced in
centralized markets.
We're instead
optimally allocating
assets across
households, but then
not forcing them to
eat the return stream.
Instead, they enter
into this risk syndicate
as if a social planner were
reallocating consumption.
Whereas, in finance you kind
of assume you're an investor.
You could do means and
variances and take some risks
on your portfolio.
And then you're going to eat
it or at least dynamically
optimize, eat some,
save some for tomorrow.
But this is very different.
And it's key that
they don't have
to eat the returns off
their capital stock
or make their own independent
savings decisions.
And you've seen last
time building up to this
that households are sharing a
lot of risk with each other.
And these informal village
money markets are quite active.
We called them a money
market last time.
So we've already been
using that language.
That's what this
slide is saying.
That's just a reminder of what
we talked about last time.
So data, it's monthly.
I don't know what they're
called, four villages grouped
together in a tombone.
So we kind of started adopting
this South Africa language.
I don't know whether I like it.
We're calling them townships.
AUDIENCE: It has a slight
connotation [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's rural and maybe
not the best place to be.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So tombone is Thai for the fact
that we picked four at random
in this geographic area.
But no one knows
what a tombone is.
But clearly, townships
distinguishes it from villages.
It's four villages
in the data anyway.
You know all about
where they're located.
Reminder that we started
in August of '98.
We're going to ignore the
first four months basically.
And use the data
from 1990 on, 1999.
We're still out
there at month 174.
What we're going to use--
and Chris and I
just basically redid
this in the last few weeks--
we're going to use month five
to 160 or basically 156 months,
or 13 full years of the data at
the monthly level for the 541
households who are
basically have not dropped
out sort of a balanced panel.
Now, about the townships, so
what percentage of households
have relatives living
in the same village?
It's a bit low into only
half in [INAUDIBLE]..
It's 3/4 in Logburi.
And Buriram is already up to
the 80s if not to the 90s.
But if you go to
the township level,
then 87, really 88 is
the lowest percent.
In other words,
almost every household
has a relative if
not in their own
village then in
a village nearby.
So we stopped kind of looking
at networks after this.
And networks confuse
people, rightly so.
Because who's in it?
And who isn't?
And is there selection
bias, and so on?
So we just made it
easy for ourselves
and said, ah, they're all really
related to each other anyway.
So let's use the whole sample.
But I'll show you what
we go back and check.
This looks like risk and
return in village India.
I mean, you can see the
cultivation activities,
livestock, fish, shrimp,
wage earning, and so on.
Wage earning is a bit
heavier in the Northeast.
And in [INAUDIBLE]
only [INAUDIBLE]
has fish and shrimp.
It sounds like a restaurant.
I know I've already
told you though.
That's what you're eating
when you buy shrimp at Costco.
And all the business,
livestock is pretty heavy.
And Logburi, also [INAUDIBLE],,
those are the dairy cattle.
So that's just a quick
reminder of the "projects."
My project is a cow, et cetera.
It's a cash cow.
That's terrible.
And here is some just
reminder of descriptive
statistics, males,
females, education levels.
Some of this you've seen
before, income levels, assets
and liabilities, and so on.
So we're going to
use a total return.
And we're going to
include financial assets.
We're not going to separate--
by the way, it's
a bit problematic
to know what to do
with a savings account.
It's a financial asset.
But on the other hand,
maybe like inventory,
it's kind of contributing
to the business.
And if we didn't have it in
there, then people would ask.
So it didn't make
much difference.
So we put in all the
financial assets.
Actually, subtracted
off the debts too.
It doesn't really matter.
If you want to think about
this as real rates of return,
you would not be misled
in real projects,
real people, real assets.
OK, you know we constructed
these financial accounts.
This is problematic.
We have to sort of subtract
off the cost of labor.
And when it's household
labor, it's not priced.
This is probably our
single biggest problem.
And when I show you residual
rates of return in a minute,
you'll see some of them are low.
We probably subtracted
off too much.
But it's very hard to know.
Because we try to grab
instruments and adjust.
But it's really kind of
not terribly compelling.
You'll see this again when
we get to the labor paper.
So we adjust the income.
We divide by fixed assets.
That, as you know, is
rate of return on assets.
We may get real.
The data is nominal.
It's all measured
in Thai [INAUDIBLE]..
So we deflate by Bank of
Thailand regional price
changes.
This is the table of the
rates of return mean standard
deviation and the so-called--
so I forgot to say it.
But that thing I kept
saying was sort of
like a coefficient
of variation, that's
like the inverse Sharpe ratio.
So you can add that
to your vocabulario.
Now, each household
has a sample average.
So you're going to have a mean
standard deviation, et cetera,
those statistical moments
for every single household.
So you have a histogram
in the population.
So you can look at the
median mean if you want,
if it's not too confusing, or
the 25th and 75th quartiles
of rates of return.
Some of them are high.
Many of them are not that high.
But in any event, these
are not adjusted at all.
They're just the
crude rates of return.
OK, so now we got to decide what
to do with the risk free rate.
Well, these are
supposed to be real.
So we're basically
going to assume
they have something
like inventory that
goes up with the price level.
And there's nothing
stochastic about it.
So we're going to assume the
real rate of return is zero.
Now again, if we're
guessing wrong about this,
we're going to be guessing
wrong about the intercepts.
Because everything we do
is subtracting off zero.
But anyway, that's what we do.
The market return is the
average township rate of return.
And again, that's just
looking at the income
over all the households
divided by all the assets.
We're about to run
a regression though.
So we will take out the
household's own contribution
to the village average.
It's like a leave out mean.
So we don't you know bias
it in the obvious way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Depreciation
is in here.
Because depreciation is a cost
that we're subtracting off
in the financial accounts.
AUDIENCE: So that's where
it comes [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Uh-huh.
So these numbers are basically
coming off of the income
as in the income statement.
And the assets as in
the balance sheet,
which you've seen before.
Although, it is true that
we cover a lot of ground.
So I'm happy to remind you.
So how do we get
the relationship
of the household's rate of
return to the village average?
We run a regression.
We run a regression
of the household's,
over all of its projects,
household's return at day t.
But there are lots of dates
t with all those months--
more on that in a second--
regressed against the
village return at day t.
OK, so this beta
is just literally
the regression coefficient
that we wanted conveniently.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: We are
assuming [INAUDIBLE]
is constant over time
for each household?
PROFESSOR: OK, so yeah,
there's several adjustments.
I think it's on the next page.
But anyway, so actually,
what we're going to do
is do five year increments.
You could just
take one household
over all the many
years and months
and ignore possible
shifts in their portfolio.
But like you're saying,
that might be a bad idea.
So we redid it as
if the household
had returns on a
portfolio from year one
through five then returns
on a portfolio from year two
through six, seven
through eight,
and so on all the way through.
And it turns out that
idea, as many others,
come from the
finance literature.
So that's what we're doing.
The other adjustment I should
have mentioned earlier.
And I didn't.
But you remember when we
use a quadratic utility
it was a plus b times
something, right?
And there was no
t on those things.
So it was like the
marginal utility of wealth
just depends on wealth.
And it doesn't depend
on anything else.
But in many
intertemporal models,
those things would
be moving around.
So I'll tell you about
that adjustment too.
We actually did it all
the different ways.
But these are the key steps.
We run the regression,
or regressions,
for each household.
And then we get the beta
for each household j.
And we get the average return,
either over all the years
or over these five
year increments.
And then we run this
regression essentially
with this already coming from
a previous regression using
the panel.
This thing is just a
cross-sectional regression.
There's no time date here.
This is the average return.
This is the extent
to which the village
that household's returns are
correlated with the village
average.
And we'll get expressions
for lambda, alpha, and so on.
And there are restrictions.
Although, you no doubt
can't remember seven
and a half slides back
that and this lambda
ought to be equal to something
like the expected market
rate of return.
Just take my word for it.
We don't impose
that restriction.
So here's the first result.
Beta is on the right hand side.
And it's being regressed against
the household's mean rate
of return and three
of the four provinces.
It's quite positive
and significant.
These are the regression
coefficients, the lambdas
basically.
And this is the
estimated constant.
And r squares.
You know what it is.
It's kind of worth noting.
Buriram fails and has
a very low r square.
And Buriram is one
of the places I've
mentioned, where the farmland
got plowed over with roads.
And the town was being built up.
So there arguably were a lot
of changes in occupations.
We'll try to fix that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this for
one five year period?
Or is this like an
average of the--
PROFESSOR: This is actually,
with treating each household
multiple times.
AUDIENCE: OK, so--
PROFESSOR: I think.
Let me just see.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] it's
like putting 20 years.
PROFESSOR: No, it's not yet.
AUDIENCE: So that's
like the whole thing.
PROFESSOR: This is
the whole thing.
AUDIENCE: So do we have to
worry about [INAUDIBLE] issues
or [INAUDIBLE] problems with us?
Or is that not-- do
I misunderstood how
the regression [INAUDIBLE]?
So is there some
possibility that there's
like going to be trends in the
errors that are not picked up?
Because you set the constant.
[INAUDIBLE] So we don't have
to worry too much about using
the whole--
PROFESSOR: We
worried quite a bit
about potential econometric
biases and so on and so forth.
Then we went back
and read the classics
in finance, [INAUDIBLE],,
French, all these guys.
And we're doing
what they're doing.
So we felt better.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
if we regress
the errors on the [INAUDIBLE],,
does it pause the test?
Or is it--
PROFESSOR: Oh, we haven't--
yeah, I don't think we've looked
for autocorrelation and stuff
like that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] we
get hammered three hours
and make that [INAUDIBLE].
That's what we're
doing [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: The HH factor.
OK, we'll check that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So do you
think it's worse
to joint tested r [INAUDIBLE]
j for each household,
like the finance guys?
PROFESSOR: We're about
to show you the alphas.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: I haven't
gotten there yet.
We'll see when I get
there whether you have
something different in mind.
Anyway, so if you
want to visually see
sort of a mean
variance frontier,
you the beta is down here.
That's kind of the risk factor,
if you believe this model.
And the expected
returns are here.
And you can see a
pretty close fit.
Now, this I've shown
to the finance guys
at lunches and things.
And they're like, wow.
Because this is
actually pretty good
relative to New York
financial markets.
Oh, it's an easy target, OK.
So so far we are showing
that just to repeat,
when someone has a higher
return, it's partly not talent.
It's just that it's correlated
with the village average.
And it's high because you
need to adjust for the risk.
Now, we can do this at the
village level, in which case
nine of the 16
villages we're going
to have this positive
correlation that the theory
says ought to be there.
And when we go to
the network level,
we have five out
of nine networks.
And I'll show you
about the adjustments,
remind you here's
a kinship network.
206 is married with
207 in some way.
And 214 has all these.
So can it literally
connect the dots?
Here's a big dynasty down here.
Here's a little dynasty there,
another little dynasty there.
So we went through
all the villages.
And they had to have
enough data to do this.
So we ended up with networks.
Now, some villages have
more than one, et cetera.
So of the nine with
enough data, we're
picking up the theory
doing well here and not
in some of the other ones.
So as I said, we go micro,
go macro, zooming in and out.
There's a lot of explanation
of the rate of return.
That has to do with
the village average.
This is villages.
OK, so this has to do with
changing projects, basically.
So it's what I said.
We use these sort of five
year intervals and redo it.
And kind of reassuringly,
Buriram pops back in there.
Because Buriram was
the place for sure
that I know that they switched
occupations quite a bit
and moved from lower to
higher rates of return.
So it's kind of reassuring,
given the previous work
to see that this adjustment
allows us to recover something.
Although, the r square
is nothing to brag about.
Now, another hard thing, easy
and hard at the same time,
is human capital,
not physical capital.
So as you know, a lot of these
households have laborers.
They're earning wages.
And you say, well, what's that
the fruit of what tree is that?
Well, the tree is human capital.
Of course, you never
really see that.
You can write big H. And you
have the notation for it.
But what is it really?
Unfortunately, we don't need
the measure of their stock.
All we need to do
is measure the flow.
So basically, it's
not quite right.
But largely, the
return on human capital
are the wages these
households are earning.
And we will now put that
in the equation as well.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask you a
question about [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So the
way I understand
this is rather than something
like skill and talent,
you're saying people
[INAUDIBLE] returns,
because they're somewhere all
along this return frontier.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: So once we
think of this model,
like how do we then respond
to the big questions
of the puzzles of
heterogeneous returns?
Do we know what--
PROFESSOR: Well,
we don't know yet.
I haven't shown you.
Maybe there's no puzzle.
That's the point.
People aren't adjusting.
AUDIENCE: But there's still--
PROFESSOR: But anyway, not
to keep you in suspense.
It is going to turn out
that there is a residual.
And then we can see
what it's related to.
And I actually said
it's wealthy females who
have the high residual
rate of return.
AUDIENCE: So
essentially the question
is, given that they're on that
[INAUDIBLE] regression line,
which ones are where and why?
And part of the answer
might be explained by--
PROFESSOR: Well,
there is part of it
that we're not explaining, even
in the definition of the model,
in the construction
of the model,
and another part that's
outside the model altogether.
What we're not
doing very well is
why household j is
running project i
and some other household is not.
We're just acting like
the social planner knew
and efficiently allocated
projects across households.
So that part is sort of
related to the talent thing.
But we never see it.
We can only look at
the residual return,
which actually ought to be
zero if the model is true.
Anyway, so another adjustment
that I've mentioned
is that a plus bw thing.
And you might want to
have time subscript.
Sorry, I'm jumping ahead.
Here's the human capital thing.
So now the rate of return has
two factors a la, basically,
[INAUDIBLE] type thing, OK?
One is the physical capital.
And the other is human capital.
And we can try to
get both betas.
Another is this problem with
the varying shadow prices.
Well, another way to say this
mu, act like mu is a constant.
Mu t is the value of
resources at day t.
In the derivation, it was
always today versus tomorrow.
And it kind of got suppressed.
But suppose a village
has a run of bad luck,
like [INAUDIBLE],, with those
shrimp ponds going bad.
Then they have less
and less income.
So you would think
mu t is going up.
Because the marginal value,
the shadow price is going up.
So we really do need
to adjust for that.
But there again,
there's a way to do it.
It turns out that time
varying stochastic discount
factor is related to the
consumption wealth ratio.
And in turn, the law
consumption wealth ratio
depends on three factors,
consumption, physical wealth,
and basically, labor earnings.
Rather than getting bogged
down in the details,
I think intuitively
you could just think,
well, you know, there's
physical capital.
So basically, the
consumption wealth ratio
is kind of picking up the
degree to which they have wealth
today relative to consumption.
So that's kind of like
an obvious argument
to have in today's shadow price.
And these things that
determine the consumption
wealth, or the law consumption
wealth ratio, kind of look
like the accounting variables
that we've had before.
You know, how much you eating?
Again, how much is your
physical capital today?
And then how much is
your labor earnings?
So that's kind of
the spirit of it.
Again, do our homework and we
can find this exact derivation
in the literature.
So this consumption asset
ratio just looks like this.
So we find that in the
data by regressing it
on to the arguments
that I just mentioned,
consumption and so on.
And then we substitute
in that estimated value
into the regression that already
was adjusted for human capital.
So now we just did
a double adjustment.
We put human capital in the
rate of return on human capital.
And now we have
extra data terms that
have to do with the covariance
of those physical and human
capital returns with this.
So basically, we're
just interacting.
We have levels of things.
And then we're interacting
it with the rates of return.
So we do that.
We end up with this.
It's a longer equation.
And we run it.
And we're still getting the
beta on physical capital.
It's quite hardy.
It's quite robust.
Human capital is in there
sometimes, sometimes not.
But at least putting it
in doesn't harm this.
In other words, as I said,
we do all the adjustments
that we can.
And we're still getting
the basic result back out.
Now, you want to
know about risk?
Well, this is the equation
that we're running.
So you can do a
decomposition of variance.
The total variance in
returns is just the variance
having to do with the
regression times the variant,
or basically, this thing.
This is the contribution
of market risk
to the variance of household j.
And there's a residual here that
we were just chatting about.
So we estimate its variance.
And so that's the contribution
of idiosyncratic risk
to the overall variance.
So now, we have this
measure, finally.
But note that it didn't just
come from using the data.
We used the structure of
the model to back it out.
And that idiosyncratic part
is large, at least half
and in many instances.
Substantially more
than half of the risk
is due to the idiosyncratic
component, rather than
the aggregate.
Now, one word of caution.
We still haven't
rejected the model.
No one in finance says there
aren't idiosyncratic returns.
The question is
whether they're priced.
If you believe in the capital
asset model or the consumption
based risk sharing model,
then idiosyncratic returns
can exist.
But they're completely pooled.
So this per se does
not reject the model.
But when we now
stick the variance,
sigma j, into the
benchmark model.
And we're still doing
OK with aggregate risk.
But here's the
rejection, if you like.
The idiosyncratic
risk is positively
associated with
expected rate of return
and for all the households.
Now, this is the if you
like, the disappointing part,
or the tension, which
is you go to all
this work with a benchmark.
And it seems to be
doing really well.
But there are features
of the data against which
it's not doing well.
So it's clear that it's not
an entirely perfect markets
world from the point of
view of the rate of return
of these assets.
But is the glass half
empty or half full?
Because it's also true
that a substantial amount
of the rates of return had
to do with market risk.
And most development
researchers would
have ignored that market part.
I think it's fair to
say, even though it's
kind of a natural
corollary to risk sharing.
So let's go back
to these alphas.
So Jensen talks about having
portfolio managers who
are somehow smarter
or better than others.
And they have abnormal returns.
I mean, I don't know.
This is kind of
hard for economists.
It's like, well, if you do
so well, why don't everyone
just go in there?
Like, I never make money.
I don't trust my instincts.
But I'll tell you
story about Walmart.
So one of my colleagues who
was at Chicago, a sociologist,
was in Arkansas.
And he saw this big square flat
building in northern Arkansas.
And he sort of checked
it out and said,
well, this is a really
novel way of doing business.
Well, it turned out to be
practically the first branch
of Walmart.
And he bought stock.
He did quite well obviously.
Anyway, so maybe some
portfolio managers
are better than others.
Maybe some households are
somehow better than others.
And we've now got a way of
adjusting for all those risk
factors, both the idiosyncratic
and the aggregate.
By the way, you will
be relieved a bit
maybe to know that
when we rank order
the households by the
unadjusted rates of return
and the risk adjusted
rates of return,
the ordering is
largely preserved.
But the orders of
magnitude are not.
The second point is
it's not just completely
downshifting the distribution
after you subtract stuff off.
The tails come in.
So it has a different
level of skewness.
So it's kind of a serious
filter on the data.
But some of the earlier
results that poor households
have high rates of return and
reinvest in their own projects,
we're going to rerun those.
But we're pretty confident those
kind of results don't go away.
And I haven't misled you
in the earlier lectures.
So finally, here is running
these regressions, where
we have aggregate risk,
also allow idiosyncratic
risk, where we have the betas
on aggregate physical capital
and the coefficients on sigma.
So the first two slides I
said households who are older
take on less risk,
which means basically,
both the idiosyncratic
and aggregate risk
factors are negative.
You might be willing to tell
a demographic story for that.
We don't really have it
embedded in the model.
It's more like a residual or
behavioral thing at this point.
Because these residuals
aren't supposed to be there.
And here is basically the
wealth again, negative.
So poor people have higher
correlation of their activities
with a village average.
And the residual have a
higher residual variance.
I'm going to come back to that.
Poor people seem to be
exposed to a lot of risk.
However, if you take out both
sources of risk and regress
on demographics and
all these things,
wealth finally goes positive.
And also, this is a dummy for
male, so to speak, is negative.
So that the female headed
households and the high wealth
households are the households
with the highest sort
of residual rates of return.
OK, so now what I don't have
in front of me unfortunately,
we didn't quite
get close enough.
But you may remember that
QJE paper from lecture one
on volatility, growth,
finance, what's related?
And we said, well, we've
got to look at sectors.
We've got to figure out how
much each sector is contributing
to overall change
in value added.
And there was some really
cool decomposition.
So we're running that
on these Thai data.
So we can see at
the level of income
how diversified are
these households?
It's similar, but not identical
to this CAPM type approach.
And so far at least, we're
getting the same answer,
that it's the relatively poor
households who are specialized.
And the things
they specialize in
have high volatility, and so on.
So poor people seem
to be exposed to risk
at least on the income side.
So here's moving to Sweden,
more sort of standard asset
stuff, which John
Campbell and co-authors
have done called Down or Out.
And what they're trying
to do is very similar.
They're trying to look
at household management
of financial affairs
using measurement
in this amazing Swedish data.
Sweden is a socialist
country largely.
And they measure everything.
And everyone has a common
ID, and your whole portfolio,
labor supply, everything.
So I've been
collaborating a little bit
with a Riksbank largely
influenced by this paper.
Now unfortunately, it takes
us away from development.
That's not my point.
My point is the commonality.
They're going to look at
mean variance frontiers
and see what
households are doing.
In particular, what are the poor
people doing or the rich ones?
The focus is a bit
different, which is
households can make mistakes.
In other words, let's just
assume the model is right.
And the mean
variance frontier is
what it is and then see
households in the interior who
could get less variance
or a higher mean
if they only move
to the frontier.
And then they look
by characteristics,
like education,
wealth, and so on
to see who is
under diversified--
those are the down people--
and who's not participating
as in the stock market.
Those are the out people.
And hence the title, very
clever, Down and Out.
And they measure the welfare
costs of those deviations.
As I said, they
have amazing data.
And here you can see sort of how
households manage their growth
wealth in Sweden.
This is the cash.
Oh, look at that.
Poor people have a lot of cash.
I think cash just doesn't
mean Swedish krona.
I think it also
means bank accounts.
But stocks, poor people
don't hold stocks.
Mutual fund has this
funny hunch-- now,
it's interesting that
this is real estate.
So this is both financial
as well as real.
And on a household side,
there are some businesses here
actually.
But most of these households
are salary employees.
But they can hold
durable goods in housing.
If you take the physical
housing wealth out of it,
then the cash thing
is still going down.
The mutual funds is largely
flat, except at the very low
and the high end.
And then you see this stock.
It's the 90 percentile
up are the people who
have reasonably substantial
holdings in the stocks.
I ask myself these
questions a lot in Thailand.
Sort of maybe they
shouldn't be investing
in their own projects.
Maybe they should be investing
in Bangkok money market
funds, safe funds.
We should be sort of looking
at the whole mean variance
frontier for these.
And we are asking them now.
We're actively involved.
I was on the phone
again last night.
We're about to be asking them
a bunch of questions about,
are they aware of other assets?
But in Sweden the point that
Campbell is going to make
is you've got those categories.
And households can make mistakes
by picking volatile assets,
holding a concentrated
portfolio, picking correlated.
See the parallel here
with what I was saying
happens in the Thai villages in
terms of relatively poor people
not being diversified
and for some reason
doing riskier things.
Or if you go in
the stock market,
you could pick your own stocks.
It's not a particularly
clever thing to do.
And this is the picture
that makes the paper.
So here's the sort
of mean variance
frontier, standard
deviation in means.
Here's where they ought to be.
Adjusting or not for
international asset holdings,
that's another.
They do both.
But they're basically saying,
small guys in some sense
are unsophisticated
and cautious.
They're pretty far
off the frontier.
But they don't have
kind of a lot to lose.
And these richer guys up here,
they're more sophisticated.
Their line is quote unquote
above this brown one.
But their gap is huge.
So I'll spare you the details.
They're actually measuring
the welfare loss.
And some of these
richer households are--
because they are not
diversifying-- actually
have fairly substantial
welfare losses.
Now, John goes behavioral in
this and maybe rightly so.
He's saying should we really
be telling households in Brazil
about investing in
whatever is [INAUDIBLE]..
I can't remember the acronym.
Or are they going
to make mistakes
and they're better
off not knowing?
There was a question.
AUDIENCE: This is already
answered by the model,
but this is welfare.
This takes into account the
marginal utility of wealth.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, actually,
I'm sparing you a lot.
Oh, I should say.
This is on the reading list.
But I knew I wasn't
going to have time
to cover it in much detail.
So I picked like six slides.
But I'll post the whole paper.
If you're interested,
you don't necessarily
want to or have time to
read the whole paper.
You might as well look
at these lecture notes
that I created previously.
And the same thing
for this paper,
which is [INAUDIBLE] with
[INAUDIBLE],, Dynamic Risk
Management.
I've only got a few slides.
I think I'm going to jump
and show you something.
Fly Southwest.
So this guy's
loading that airplane
that capital stock up with
this variable input, the fuel.
They buy forward positions.
Because the price of
gasoline moves around a lot.
So they basically
buy forward, OK?
They commit now to buy gasoline
at a pegged future price.
Now, what happens if the spot
price is lower than that?
It's like, oh, darn.
We should've waited.
Actually, you could
renege on that contract.
And so what do they
do with those things?
You've got to post collateral
against these forward gasoline
hedges.
Where are we going with this?
We're going to get to sort
of thinking about something
that Chris [INAUDIBLE] was
doing in Ghana, which is,
do you want to use your scarce
collateral to borrow and get
more aircraft with potentially
high rate of return?
Or do you want to use
your scarce collateral
and tie it up hedging
against future states
of the world s prime?
And this paper is about how in
practice this may not happen.
Now, when does it happen?
Where is it?
It happens when the airline
isn't doing very well.
So if you think about relatively
poor households, it's like, oh,
they're behavioral.
They're not buying insurance.
What's wrong with them?
They need it most.
They've got the
most marginal value.
Well, no, not necessarily.
They may have better use
for their existing wealth.
So we're getting again, very
explicitly now into obstacles.
So when you start writing
down models with obstacles
and barriers to
trade, you can get
at this issue about
borrowing to finance
projects versus borrowing.
So maybe it's still possible
that those relatively poor
people who seem to be
doing really risky things
and aren't hedged
against it, maybe
there's a reason for that.